why is economics not any sexier than it
is
I think economics has the
um disadvantage of being associated with
lots of like very uncool people you know
numbers data models
in the formal sense you know these are
not things that attract our attention
but it's a shame because economics is
actually pretty cool now I may not be
the best person to pitch that
idea but it is and I wish more people
saw that
what is it that people misunderstand
about what economics contains then
so one thing that people might not get
is just how broad it is right so so many
people think of economics in terms of
like stock markets housing markets
inflation rates and things and that is
part of Economics that is one of the
things that or some of the things that
economists study but economics is so
much broader than that it's about
anything and everything connected to
human well-being any choice that you
make that has any implications for the
way you live your life and the way
things turn out so that means you can do
economics and study crime uh child
rearing climate change
family formation whatever you like
there's likely to be an economic angle
to it and in fact if you think about
like the big problems like whichever
problem you're thinking about I bet
there's an economic angle to that as
well right there's going to be some
economic implications or some economic
perspective perspective and in many
cases some economic tool that you can
use to to address it what do you mean
when you say an economic angle like what
are you referring to what is the toolkit
or the world view or the Paradigm
through which economics looks at these
sorts of things what I'm thinking about
primarily is a way of looking at human
decisions and basically everything is a
result of human decisions right
everything's social and even if it isn't
the solution to whatever problem you're
thinking about is gonna involve human
behavior and when economists think about
that what they think about is the
various values that are at stake
oftentimes we have to make choices right
because there's a limited amount of
whatever we care about and what that
means that we have to strike a balance
between the different things we have to
give up a little bit of this in order to
get a little bit of that now some people
out there want everything always said
once right that's childish once you see
that the world isn't designed like that
you got to think about the ways in which
things come at a cost cost and that's
the core of what economics has to offer
a way of looking at decisions that
brings to the fore the values that are
at stake the costs involved but also the
benefits that you can get from making
the best available decision
speaking of making economics a little
bit sexier a Yale economics professor
has some ideas for how to deal with the
burdens of Japan's rapidly aging Society
the only solution he said is mass
suicide of the elderly including ritual
disembowelment I noticed that you shared
this article with a massive face palm
about what your Japanese colleagues are
doing in in interviews and public
appearances yusiki Narita an assistant
professor of Economics at Yale has taken
on the question of how to deal with the
burdens of Japan's rapidly aging Society
I feel like the only solution is pretty
clear he said during the online news
program in late 2021 in the end isn't it
mass suicide and mass sepoku of the
elderly seppuku is an act of ritual
disembowelment that was a code among
dish Dishonored Samurai in the 19th
century
um
or throwing yourself off a cliff like in
mid-summer he suggested a little bit
later with with all respect to my
colleagues at Yale I think that's a
fundamentally uneconomic way of looking
at the world right anytime somebody says
this is the only way this is the only
solution that means that they're not
recognizing the trade-offs involved I
think if we're going to think about
aging populations and the sort of
burdens that that's going to come with
and the benefits as well we've got to
look at the full range of of costs and
benefits at the end of the day the
economist is not going to be best
situated to say well this is the right
option right given all the costs and
benefits because that's a question about
values at the end of the day and that's
not really what we do what we do as
economists is to think about well if we
want to attain this goal like what do we
have to sacrifice in order to get there
and if we want to avoid mass suicide
right which we do then we we as
economists can save things like well
here are the options right we can go
down this path we can go down that path
and now you people decide you people
meaning voters and you know fellow
citizens out there what are some of the
potential advantages of an aging
population
this isn't really my area so I hesitate
to sort of speak out of line but um
there are benefits with older
populations clearly you can see it in
the workplace right we have we have as
speaking as one of the older people
um we have experience and knowledge and
things that it's got to be possible to
take advantage of
yeah it's an interesting one I think the
difference between an aging population
and an elderly population is is probably
pretty important because what we're
talking about is a larger cohort of
people that can contribute in terms of
innovation in terms of being part of the
workforce driving GDP etc etc
um but as is told demography is Destiny
which means that that aged Workforce
population will eventually end up
becoming the elderly population you can
end up with an inverted pyramid which is
not necessarily fun so what I think is
interesting about your perspective is
that you've got the economics wing and
you've got the philosophy Wing as well
you're also a philosopher by training
but
philosophers also not exactly renowned
for being well liked and well respected
they're often disliked and disrespected
and now you're telling me okay look I I
I'm not saying that it's you Eric is
causing this to happen but what is it do
you think about philosophy as well it
seems like they need there's a branding
problem there's like a PR nightmare
that's occurred with both economics and
with philosophy what's your post-mortem
on the uh brand positioning of
philosophy and philosophers I worry what
it might say about me the fact that I
said on the common denominators who are
the common denominators here are such a
bad reputation
um I don't know I think we are for one
thing terrible at explaining to people
what we do so philosophy and economics
are both sort of abstruse they're
abstract they're done in a language
that's inaccessible we use mathematics
and philosophy as well as in economics
right and this means that the average
Joe can't pick up one of our journals
and get something out of it but that
doesn't mean that the stuff we're doing
isn't relevant to the people on the
street in fact it's immediately and
directly relevant to many of the the
things that we're thinking about the
ways in which we live our lives and
whatever we just don't translate it into
a language that's comprehensible to
people and much of that is a function I
think of as professional Norms so we
care about each other's approval right
we talk to each other we care about what
other people there care about think
about us we don't pay enough attention
to the people out there and the various
ways in which they might want to engage
in conversation because the fact is it
wouldn't just be good for them it would
be good for us as well when we talk
about big decisions for example we need
stakeholder involvement right economics
can't provide the values we need people
out there telling us what matters to
them what they think of as the big
problems and what sort of constraints
apply to the solutions that that we
develop so I think there's a lot of
there would be a lot of benefits to be
had from actually talking to each other
which you know we don't do in part
because of this terrible reputation that
you that you identified okay so you did
a fantastic lecture that I really
enjoyed to do with happiness and how
it's worked into a whole host of
different factors just taking a broad
view
as someone at the intersection of
philosophy and economics what do you
think common misunderstandings about
happiness Miss
what is it that people don't fully
conceptualize when they're just
considering happiness overall
so the central thing that I like to
underscore is the difference between
happiness and well-being so well-being
as I think of it as philosophers think
of it is what we have when our lives are
going well when our things are in place
when we're flourishing and so on
happiness is what we have when we're in
the certain mental state a mental state
that feels good that that that sometimes
psychologists refer to as as positive
affect and it's true that historically
people have thought of these two things
as very tightly sort of intertwined but
I think it makes a lot of sense to think
of them as slightly separate sure a good
life is a life that includes a great
deal of happiness it would be weird to
think of your life going well if you're
miserably unhappy but there are
situations when these things come apart
so there are values in life there are
goals in life that are important to us
even if they don't come with an
additional dose of happiness and even if
they come at the cost of happiness I
like to think about children actually
falling in this category there is a lot
of evidence from the science of
Happiness suggesting that having
children makes you less happy than not
having children and that if you're a
parent when you're spending time with
your kids you're less happy than when
you're doing many other things like
hanging out with your friends or
chilling in front of the television or
something but never mind having a child
can still be a good thing for you right
even if it comes at a cost so that's
that that's got your philosophy angle
right but it's got your economics angle
as well and this is a really important
thing to appreciate some things are good
for us even if they don't make us
happier
what is the way that having children
does contribute to the Improvement of
Our Lives whether that be through
well-being or meaning or whatever
there is a fair amount of evidence
suggesting that people with kids have
more meaning in their lives they feel a
part of a bigger whole they feel like
they're part of the shifts of the
generations they give satisfaction to
their parents and and so on
non-set non-financial satisfaction as
people say increases when you become a
parent the problem is that other kinds
of satisfaction go down
um notably Financial satisfaction so
having a child costs a ton of money
right now the estimates suggests it
costs like three hundred thousand
dollars before college right up to the
age 18 or something and then you stack
College costs on top of that it's a lot
of money and what that means is that
when you have a child unless you
suddenly become you know 300 000 richer
you're gonna have to make sacrifices and
those sacrifices are going to cost you
in terms of you know happiness among
other things
I've had a lot of conversations on the
podcast about declining birth rates
crises of fertility and then crises of
mating overall people just getting into
relationships and and not uh saying that
they are going their own way or
retreating into a much more siled
atomized lifestyle and one of the things
I've considered which you've touched on
there which is pretty interesting is
an over
prioritization of the immediate
and because we live in a world which is
hyper convenient
the immediacy I said to you before I get
started it's 39 degrees here in Austin
Texas but I'm cool I'm cool because I've
got air conditioning I don't have to
wait for the air conditioning to come on
because it's on a timer so the immediacy
of our comfort and the immediacy of any
discomfort has never been more acutely
felt and I get the sense that with
declining religiosity which is sort of a
lack of awe and Dread a lack of sort of
connection to the grander plan the more
meaning making also the more
community-based activities that we would
have done previously
what people see when they look at
childhood it's having children and the
sort of ensuing three hundred thousand
dollar prison sentence is that
it's an awful lot of
non-immediate happiness look at all of
the things I'm going to have to pay a
price for up front there was a famous
Tick Tock that a girl released called
the girl with a list and she printed off
300 and something reasons why not to
have a kid and they included things like
um can't go to brunch with the girls uh
no longer able to wear cute heels so you
know people really are it's kind of
tongue-in-cheek but also people are
really optimizing for this stuff on the
front end what you're saying is that
overall the meaning making machine that
children are is perhaps a net positive
but it does require you to pay a cost up
front with regards to freedom and in the
moment happiness continuously as well if
it's 3am in the morning and this is the
second time that your baby has uh pooed
in its diaper it is not going to be an
enjoyable happy experience you know you
will accrue meaning across the period of
your life but
current culture pedestalizes
happiness in the moment and uh
absolutely hates any detraction away
from that so much that I think we have a
a culture which is essentially
unconducive to meaning making and given
that children are mostly meaning making
machines I think that that explains at
least part of of what's going on what do
you think about my bro science
hypothesis yeah no absolutely so if one
off like first off recognizing that
having children is awfully hard is
really important right you have these
nights when you cannot sleep at all
because they're screaming because
they're sick or whatever and
um sleeplessness is terrible it's
terrible for your thinking for your
effect for irritability right it's
terrible for your immune system and
there's just so much evidence suggesting
that that's bad for for a person and
hard it's also true that we tend to
focus on short-term gains to a very
great extent there's a ton of evidence
on hyperbolic discounting as as they
call it right if you're standing if you
have the choice between a remote benefit
a remote good like you know adoring
children or something or going to brunch
with your friends going to branch is
going to seem like such a good idea when
it's right in front of you even if when
you reflect on it you recognize that
adoring children is a much bigger value
to to you so so that's really important
and then I think in certain ways
parenting has gotten harder right we've
in other ways it's gotten better but we
live we're lonelier now in a sense we
live especially in America very far from
our families we can live thousands of
miles obviously from our our families in
other times and in other places you
would live closer to your family you
would have parents cousins nieces
nephews aunts and uncles some of whom
wouldn't have their own children who
might really benefit from hanging out
with yours and then raising a child is
is a more communal Endeavor which is
really really important now we live
alone very far from family we're
expected to do all this on our own at
the same time as we're working maybe 60
hours a week right 80 in the worst case
if if you're a young person you're
trying to build a career you need an
apartment you have payments on your car
right you can't just stay home with a
kid if you also have to make ends meet
and so we're putting an awful lot of
awful awfully heavy burden on the
shoulders of young people who might
otherwise want to have kids now it's
true that not everybody does right
probably not everyone
ought to have kids but many people do
and the obstacles are are very
tall
yeah it seems that the biggest
disparity between uh desired and
realized fertility so the people who
wanted the number of kids that they have
compared to the number of kids that they
wanted is the biggest are educated women
and the more educated and the more smart
you are the bigger that disparity and I
don't know whether there is a
correlation between desire to have
children and IQ or whatever in women but
I can imagine that if you are somebody
who is quite smart and quite well
educated the bottom line is you've just
spent lots of time in school that's lots
of time being poor and relying on
student loans and probably living away
from your parents and all of the support
structures and not having kids yet so
you know even aside from the motivations
you just don't have the time as much I
will say that constraints differ across
countries so this is one thing that pops
up in the happiness data if you look at
like Gallup data for example which comes
out of basically every country across
the world the effects of having a child
varies by location there are a couple of
things going on there I think so some of
it might have to do with culture Right
In some cultures you're more family
oriented you can depend on your
relatives to a much greater extent than
you can in in others
development matters if there's more
money to go around in a country that
makes it easier to be apparent there
than if you're in a place with very
little resources but also some places
offer public policies that make life
easier for parents so things like
parental leave right allowing you to
spend a year maybe with your kid with a
salary and then being able to return to
the workplace right that cushions you
against some of the financial strain
that you might feel otherwise
um Healthcare right so having a child
isn't just expensive it's also
unpredictable like some people have kids
they're always healthy and happy they
you know what they cost it's not too bad
but other kids have very large needs and
need a lot of additional resources if
you can depend on support for those
sorts of of needs well that's going to
make your life a lot easier so there are
things that some places do for people
that make it easier to have kids and
that make happiness if not go up at
least not go down by as much as it does
in the U.S continental Europe looks
better from this perspective than the US
and the UK for example and the
suggestion is that it has to do with
public policy and the conditions that
new parents in particular are facing
America is ruthless you get three and a
half days off and you're expected to be
back in the office answering emails
while they're still cutting the
umbilical cord right and Healthcare is
tied to your employer to a very great
extent right so if you want to be home
you risk getting fired you would also
lose your health insurance right during
during a period of time where you're
physically more vulnerable perhaps than
you would have been previously exactly
and every new parent worries about their
kids right even if they're perfectly
healthy there are so many things you're
going to worry about and having access
to Medical Care is obviously critical I
never thought about that I never I never
thought about the essential Ransom that
new parents are held to in America by
the the fact that their medical cover is
covered by their employer yeah that's
very interesting you're going back going
back to the um the money and happiness
relationship what is the answer to
whether or not money can buy happiness
you can it can so there's a Slightly
bizarre conversation going on but people
have been doing happiness research for
literally a hundred years and there's
never been any doubt about the fact that
more money makes at least some people
happier so if you look at poor people
people at the bottom end of the income
scale everyone has found that giving
them more money on the average will make
them happier the conversation the
scholarly conversation that's been going
on for some time has to do with what
happens on the other side of the income
distribution so if you look at the very
rich does the curve become flat meaning
there's no additional benefit from
making more money after a certain point
or does it continue to rise and right
now it seems like a consensus is
emerging which says that happiness
increases at every level of income but
it increases less and less the more
money you make so economists talk about
diminishing marginal returns right and
that's what we see to find in the
happiness data now it matters what you
have to give up in order to get that
additional chunk of cash it's not always
going to be the case that you should try
to make more money if you want to be
happier because you might have to
sacrifice a Leisure right of golfing
time with friends time with family time
with your kids things like things like
that so you shouldn't sort of infer that
you should always try to maximize your
your income there's a point at which you
would be better off not but all things
equal getting more money seems to be
making you happier no matter where you
are in the distribution what is the
relationship between money and life
satisfaction well-being meaning
happiness where do where are we accruing
the biggest gains where are we paying
the biggest prices
well so those things are all correlated
right meaning happiness satisfaction
money they're they're correlated at the
national level and at the individual
individual level they do seem to come
apart in certain places so if you look
at a very rich there's evidence that
satisfaction keeps Rising faster than
happiness meaning sort of the way you
feel positive effect so if you ask
somebody like how satisfied they feel
with their lives like that the response
to that keeps increasing even if like
your happiness tapers off
why do you think that's the case
that I don't I don't know
um a judgment tends to respond to a
slightly different sort of factors in
your life than than your affect our
feelings
are a little weird sometimes right they
respond to things that might rationally
not make such such a big difference so
one thing about happiness is that it
seems to respond quite strongly to
expectations and whatever you're used to
or whatever it's possible that happiness
is more responsive to things like
expectations and aspirations and and
things than Judgment of satisfaction but
here I'm just guessing on the basis of
the data that I've seen yeah talk about
the role of aspiration what's that
what's the name of that guy the dude
who um tried to beat the railway machine
John Henry thank you what's the story of
him so African-American folk hero right
a tragic hero he was a railroad man
um he built railroads at a time when
people started producing machines to
compete with humans he he John Henry uh
thought he was going to be better than
the machine he went um into a
competition with a machine and he's a
tragic hero because he won he was right
but he died in in Victory this is
interesting to to me and to some other
people because you can think of a
personality characteristic along these
lines some people are just more like
John Henry than others right some have
ambition goals in life you know they set
they have aspirations they don't give up
easily and so on other people are more
like couch potatoes they don't really
have goals and and so on they don't have
very high expectations or aspirations
and there's a certain amount of evidence
suggesting that how happy you are is a
function both of what you attain and how
much you've aspired for what you were
hoping for in such a way that the more
you get the happier you are but the more
you Aspire the less the more you aspire
to the less happy you are and I've
worked a little bit on this and and what
do you expect to find in the data is
exactly what you find people with very
high goals in life may attain a little
more than others but they look less
happy than other people I feel like I
see this in class right I teach College
some students come in they got a B on
the exam they hate it they're so upset
because they expected an a right other
people come in they got a D they're
going to go partying they're so pleased
because they were sure they were going
to fail and so how happy you are with
your performance is going to reflect not
just the score you get on the exam or
whatever but your expectation right
and a slightly sort of scary thing about
this is that what this might suggest is
that in order to be happy you should
just like lower your standards right
lower your goals never try to pursue
anything never go for anything always
give up if you run into trouble or
whatever but but that would be the wrong
uh conclusion to draw right precisely
because happiness and well-being don't
always go together right there are
things that you can do that will leave
you better off even though you're less
happy having kids would count for me at
least but also accomplishing things like
running a marathon or climbing a
mountain things like that you know might
make you feel miserable sailing it might
make you feel awful but nonetheless if
you set yourself a goal you attain it
right you have reason to be proud of
yourself you're living a good life for
you in spite of the fact that you're
miserable because you're cold then
whatever yes no one's ever been happy
whilst running a marathon but afterwards
many people that complete it will
probably say yeah that was very
meaningful or whatever my sense of
well-being have you ever seen any
interventions that are able to decrease
expectations whilst not decreasing
aspiration
I am not sure about that I can't think
of any intervention that I'm aware of
that that would be the magic pill yeah
maybe if you could work on one yeah I
don't know the it's interesting the
standard thing right and language is so
messy here because what people are
talking about
they're often conflating lots of
different things together you know the
um falling short of what it is that you
wanted to do makes you feel bad but we
also know that there is a degree of good
that comes along with the achievement
overall so we're talking about
expectation and well-being and happiness
and aspiration all kind of gets bundled
up together but it's a nice conception
to think about the fact that
you know in the ideal scenario
you would regularly beat your
expectations I suppose the problem is
that your expectations and your
aspirations are going to be quite
tightly tied together which suggests
that the more you expect
of yourself the more you aspire to the
higher your goals the closer you get to
achieving some things you know the
people that consistently over achieve
like ridiculously overachieve over and
over and over again that doesn't happen
by accident they're not just doing this
like oh there we go again the king of
the world for the third time in a row or
whatever like it's just it doesn't
happen it's people purposefully
neurotically going out of their way to
very carefully design a system that
creates this outcome or one that's what
very similar to it I think
well actually how how have you given
this sort of knowledge that you have
around where satisfaction comes from
happiness aspiration expectation how
have you adjusted your own approach to
your life to try and integrate this to
maximize your sense of well-being and
happiness
now I don't want to hold up myself as a
model in this regard at all but I did
read up on a literature on goal
regulation there's a whole psychology of
gold regulation which is precisely about
this like how do you select goals in
life to motivate you to accomplish
things you know to live the best life
that you can without tripping yourself
up right so we agree that you need some
goals to to perform right we ought to
have goals they make life worth living
they structure our existence and so on
but at the same time there are limits to
the goals that you should set for your
for yourself and I'll say that one of
the things that I've done quite
successfully is to be satisfied with
being mediocre in almost everything if
it comes to like sports uh uh all sorts
of activities music I sometimes enjoy
engaging in these activities but I'm
perfectly happy being mediocre then
there are a couple of things that I do
in my work I want to do the best
possible work like the best work I can
do the best work that that anyone can do
I fail right in all sorts of ways but
that's my goal but in this very narrow
little domain in my sub sub-discipline
of the academic world or or whatever but
being happy with mediocrity I think is
is really great and it's something that
more people should try
that's very interesting because there
would be an argument to be made that how
you do anything is how you do everything
that
um setting yourself high standards is uh
advantageous and it will begin to bleed
across you know if you make your bed and
your pajamas are always folded and the
kitchen counter is always cleaned and so
on and so forth that this is just going
to seep into all of the other areas of
your life and the reverse as well that
if you don't do those things you're just
going to become a lazy piece of [__] in
your academic career now I don't
disagree with you I mean maybe that
works for somebody else right but what
worked for me is just settling in like
almost every domain except the ones that
I really care about and that I focus on
yeah so I haven't talked about
comparative advantage right it's
focusing where you do best relative to
what others are up to and this is an
application of that idea yeah I would
not be the best at house cleaning or
whatever which is why we've got it made
we have a maid that comes around and she
does a house so I've sacrifice some of
the things I am good at which is making
money for something that she's good at
which is cleaning the house
um one of my friends has a coach of some
kind and he told me a few months ago
that this coach has got him
he made him take up a hobby
and he had to not care about how good he
was at the Hobby and I think the hobby
that he took up was something to do with
art it was some kind of watercolor
painting or drawing or some sort of
something maybe it was even in a class
still life class or something and there
is a part of him he's quite a
hard-charging type A type guy and there
was a bit of him that just wanted to
right I'm gonna go home and I'm gonna
watch all of the YouTube videos about
how to become better at my art style and
I'm going to get all of the best pencils
and I'm going to do extra work outside
and his coach said you are forgetting
the purpose of the exercise the purpose
of the exercise is to do a thing simply
for doing a thing do you enjoy it when
you go and you try this thing it's like
yeah I'd enjoy it more if I was better
and she's like that's not the point the
point is for you to be able to let go of
the desire to be better at this thing
it's a very very interesting
like intersection or vector that we're
talking about which is in a world where
everybody applauds
growth and development and I do too it's
one of the things that I've taken an
unbelievable amount of Joy from in my
life
how do you draw is it possible to draw
boundaries around that Beyond which you
can let go which actually teaches you
lessons of where to which Hills to stand
on with a flag and then start swinging a
sword and which Hills to say looks like
the cleaner is going to get this one or
looks like I'm going to be [__] as an
artist or do you know what I mean
because I do think I do think that
there's a an Associated psychological
suffering that comes with holding
yourself to an incredibly high standard
across the board and and this is the I
suppose the behavioral economics element
of this or the behaviorist element of
this it's unrealistic like you know you
know that
if expectations as soon as you posit an
expectation for yourself and you fall
short of it that's going to create a
degree of suffering the fewer
expectations that you have especially
the ones that you do not need to have
does it matter about how straight the
bed is does it really matter or would it
be better let's imagine a world in which
you could Silo off compartmentalize the
different elements of things that you
have to be good at in your life okay
well if I could
be great at Academia
and not give a [__] about how the bed's
made I would no longer need to make the
bed
so it's almost like our expectation of
This Global how you do anything how you
do is how you do everything movement
is becomes self-fulfilling in a way and
and inescapable and maybe not actually
that advantageous this isn't exactly an
answer to your question but so often it
seems to me that we should focus more on
consistent practice than on outcomes if
I wanted to become a marathon runner and
I measured my performance by reference
to the best marathon runner out there I
would feel short every day right I would
feel awful about myself every time I
went out there so the key to becoming a
runner is to commit to a certain
training schedule you go out there you
train every day or whatever and if you
keep it up even if the only thing you
care about is the outcome you're better
off focusing on consistent practice than
constantly trying to measure up your
performance against some effectively
unattainable yardstick and I think that
it applies in lots of domains I had a
phase in college when I wrote poetry I
sat down I wrote a poem I compared it to
like the best poem of whoever I was
reading at the time I'm Leonard Cohen
and then I said look this is not as good
as he's and I tossed it and I stopped
right that's a sure path to failure if I
really wanted to become a poet I would
have had stick with it independently of
how good it was right and so to some
extent we need to select like which Hill
we're going to climb right to stick with
your metaphor and then just do it right
now which climb which climb should you
attempt well that's going to depend on
your values it might depend on like what
you have a natural talent for and so on
for sure it might depend on things like
what your friends are up to sometimes
it's more fun to climb in the presence
of of your friends but at the end of the
day that's going to be a matter of of
values but once you've committed the
best way forward is probably to commit
to a plan not to like constantly assess
your performance yes so it's got me
thinking about
um something I used to do in my old
business I run nightclubs for a long
time and when you do that you get a
guest list of people that are sent
through through and this was a period
where we were the biggest events company
in the City by an absolute Mile and this
Saturday party that we had was a monster
thousands and thousands of kids would
turn up every week so we would just have
hundreds and hundreds of groups of
people and it would be submitted as a
first name second name plus group size
right so it would be John Smith plus
five Chris Williamson plus three
whatever
I remember that there was a a long
period of probably six months to a year
where I went through and meticulously
moved the plus number
into a separate column so that all of
the numbers were completely aligned
straight up and down let's not forget
that this was a night a club night that
was making like thousands and thousands
of pounds of profit a week
and I was spending my time in the build
up to the event
moving individual numbers that had been
texted in by 18 year olds that were
pre-gaming at battered absolutely most
of them wouldn't even show up right you
know fifty percent more of the guest
list wasn't even going to show but I had
convinced myself that this was one of
the important things that needed to be
done and this is why I think a a degree
of
uh reflexive reflective uh practice okay
what are the things that I'm doing does
this contribute to the particular Hill
that I'm supposed to go up no it doesn't
you're spending 90 minutes a week
[__] about with an Excel spreadsheet
perhaps you could spend that doing
anything even if it was just watching TV
or chilling out or exercising
I guess many very successful people have
this insane attention to detail right in
architecture design or movie making or
whatever you you find that but in order
to be great at something you have to pay
attention to the right details right and
if the orientation of the pluses or
whatever really has no effect on the
outcome of the event then you know the
opportunity cost is overwhelming
what role does inequality have in
happiness so we've spoken about the fact
that
um there is a relationship although it
does taper off to do with money and
happiness it continues to go up so this
number Beyond which seventy thousand
dollars a year happiness doesn't
increase I'd already heard that that was
mostly bollocks diminishing returns
seems to make sense but I would imagine
that the curve is different if you are
living on a street filled with
millionaires so there has to be
inequality in the keeping up with the
Joneses comparison that we have in our
brains must mediate our happiness with
regards to wealth yeah I mean there's a
lot to be said about happiness and and
inequality first off there are ways in
which at least some inequality is good
for total happiness so
um some inequalities reflect preferences
for example maybe I just want to lay in
bed read a book maybe you want a ton of
money in order to travel the world and
play golf or something right
um then a maximally happy Society where
both of us get to do what we want to do
requires a certain degree or entails a
certain degree of of inequality so some
inequality is probably good for for
happiness there are other effects as
well but then there are various ways in
which an inequality or inequality can
harm total happiness so for example if
you're desperately poor and I'm super
rich and an additional dollar would make
a much bigger difference for you than
for me like you can imagine scenarios
where some degree of distribution
redistribution would make a difference
and then the keeping up with the Joneses
is is really important I think when we
assess how well we're doing in life very
often we don't look at some objective
yardstick because those things really
don't exist what we do is we compare
ourselves to somebody around us like
what's a nice car well what do I know of
right I look at the other people in my
office and see what they're driving
what's a nice watch what's uh you know
reasonable salary or whatever and to the
extent that we spend a lot of time
comparing ourselves to others we might
get involved in these like very harmful
arms races where I try to make it a
little more to have a shinier car or
whatever than you and you respond by
working a little more to have a shinier
car than me at the end of the day we're
the same right but both of us work a lot
more and we're applying money into like
you know capital goods that neither one
of us really wanted and so I think one
key to happiness is sort of opting out
on this of this process when it makes
sense all right I want the shiniest new
iPhone many of my friends get the latest
iPhone and I feel the urge to buy one
too but I succeed in talking myself out
of that and I save a lot of money that
way that I can spend on things that give
me more happiness yeah I I've thought
about this North a lot I don't have much
materialism like I'm not a very keeping
up with the Joneses person with regards
to what I own or what I wear or good
anything
I feel quite fortunate like I don't know
everything's heritable right you know
whatever everything that you are
psychologically is on average 50
heritable so I guess I have my parents
to to thank for it but I would love to
know uh what that is a materialism set
point or something or a comparative set
point what
um psychological Dimension that sits
upon and what interventions we could use
to nudge people away from that because I
I do think that it's a very low cost way
to improve people's quality of life like
you get more Bang from your book because
you are not spending your books on
things that you don't need to spend them
on right I mean we're living in a world
where one of the fastest growing sectors
of the economy is like storage right
people have so many things so many
things that they become a problem for
them a psychological problem people seek
therapy to deal with the quantities of
stuff that they've accumulated so I
think there's a lot of evidence both
from the science and from everyday
experience to suggest that we tend to
favor material belongings to a greater
extent than we probably should if we
wanted to be happy like so many people
love going camping right their best
moments is when they're in the tent
somewhere in front of a campfire and
they've got a guitar in a couple of
beers right that's the that's the spirit
like some of us really want quite simple
things and if we can see that and and
favor those sorts of things we can make
ourselves happier now of course camping
is can be super expensive right
depending on where you go and what sort
of gear you bring so this is not like a
solution that's going to work for
everyone but I think the general Insight
is true right as a result of external
pressure or you know upbringing or
whatever we tend to give too much weight
to material belongings when there are
other things that are cheaper and better
for us one of the things I was
considering to do with the level of
inequality that you could have within a
society or within a country you could
have a correlation between High GDP and
high happiness but that could be skewed
with high earners because High GDP is
contributed to overall by everyone and
likes to say that you have a country
which has captured some non-in
significant percentage of the world's
billionaires okay the the GDP is
increasing and there would be a way that
that could uh skew the relationship
between GDP and happiness have you ever
looked at this if you looked at
happiness versus inequality and GDP and
how all of that folds in yeah so I
haven't looked at it myself but I think
the general point is true in the sense
that like GDP is an average right it
takes like all the stuff that gets
produced in a country and you divide it
by the number of people GDP doesn't say
anything at all about how it's
distributed and the happiness data seems
to respond into the ways in which
various resources are distributed is
there one guy who owns everything or are
things that are distributed in a in a
different way people who need things do
they get things and and so on so you can
you can modify as it were the
relationship between happiness and GDP
by Distributing it in in various ways
and it's worthwhile thinking about that
I think is there a sex difference in
happiness
um I don't think there are any major sex
differences to my knowledge
um it's not a major factor anyway in the
literature that to my to my knowledge
yeah because we have um increasing rates
of depression and anxiety in young girls
I think that uh females overall got a
higher risk for depression and anxiety
but I think white men between the ages
of 40 and 45 are at the highest risk for
suicide at the moment so there's you
know there's kind of a a U-shaped curve
to life satisfaction which I'm sure that
you'll have seen and it seems to bottom
out at around about like 44 or something
like that yeah these sorts of things
that you're talking about ought to be
visible it seems to me in the happiness
data I just haven't looked at it like
there is evidence as as you said that
happiness over the course of the life
cyclists like u-shaped you're pretty
happy when you're young you're pretty
happy when you're old you're miserable
in the middle but then it turns out like
where I am right I'd be at the trough
there but then it matters what you
control for so you know do you control
for whether you have kids or not well
many people have like teenage kids in in
middle age and having teenage kids is
awful right they're super expensive they
stab you in the back like every day
um so much treacherous and treacherous
bastards that they are right and so the
phenomenon like what it looks like is
going to depend on to a great extent
like what you control for and then these
are averages right it doesn't apply to
each and every individual yeah this is
one of the things I was having a
conversation about
um
what was it talking about
I was talking about the differences in
the pains that people feel within the
dating Market that uh the problems that
women have and the problems that men
have and like um how many men that can't
grow any taller is worth a woman that
can't afford a boob job basically if we
were to talk about trying to create an
equivalency between the challenges that
presenting both men and women have for
increasing their visual mate value and
it's not it's it's you can't compare
these two things there is no currency
exchange between these two things and I
think that the conversation here as well
about you know are men or women happier
on average well women have got a
predisposition toward depression and
anxiety and young girls whatever sixty
percent of them say they've got
persistent feelings of hopelessness or
listlessness or something but men in the
40 to 45 range that they're killing
themselves at unprecedented rates these
aren't the same things and I think that
trying to fold them into happiness this
is one of the reasons why
um I appreciate
guys like you breaking down happiness
well-being into component parts because
I do think that there is a lot that
can't be captured when we just use
happiness to talk about how's life going
overall it's just not sufficiently
precise
yeah no I think I think that's a very
important point so you mentioned
depression right and of course there's a
correlation between uh depression and
the opposite of happiness but they're
not as correlated as you might think
right some people report laughing a lot
and they also score high on on
depression these things can come apart
so so I guess mental health or
well-being is a multi-dimensional thing
and if you want to grasp what's really
going on in your life or in society you
have to pay attention to these these
various things when it comes to unhappy
people on on The Dating Market I I I
wouldn't know my myself but to some
extent this has gotta involve
aspirations right if you're alone at
home in your bedroom and you're thinking
oh the woman or the man of my dreams is
going to look like this it's going to
have this profession it's going to make
this much money whatever you're bound to
be disappointed right it would make so
much sense to go for somebody who's kind
and generous and caring and you know who
shows up when you need them to and
whatnot than the one with a certain
height or a certain you know bra size or
what have you right aspirations matter
in in all domains probably
what about race differences in happiness
have you ever detected any of those I
have not looked at that
um uh I haven't so I has a data
um so the reason I think it's
interesting is uh you know
religion religiosity seems to be pretty
strongly correlated with levels of
happiness
um that seems to make sense to me
Community
um ritual
degree of connection to something Beyond
just you you know we talked about sort
of meaning and this sense of awe and
Dread which I do think is is really
really important but you will have
racial disparities in religiosity
so I
totally spit all this and maybe get it
wrong Mexicans on average may be more
religious than whites in America let's
say right so if you have people from
Mexico and that would show a race
difference to Central Americans in terms
of happiness but where's it actually
coming from maybe it's actually coming
from something else that's hiding within
that so the three or the four big things
that seem to be
um indicative of Happiness poverty
unemployment poor health and religiosity
those seem to be the big four is that
right you're quite right about
religiosity so that's something that
people have studied extensively and
people who are religious seem to be on
the average uh significantly happier
than atheists this is kind of
interesting it's it's not quite clear to
me where that comes from so people who
go to church regularly for example have
more companionship right they see people
they have uh they're in touch with
people they belong to a community and
those things are also known to be
conducive to to happiness so that might
be that might be part of it now an
interesting or sort of curious thing
about this result is that conservatives
have argued for a while that this proves
that we were right all along right that
uh being religious living a religious
life going to church or Temple or
whatnot is is good for a person
um and they might be right about that
there might be sort of a causal
connection between these two things but
somebody else who might have been right
was Marx so when Marx talked about
religion being opium for the people what
he meant was not that you know religion
allows you to go out and get high or or
whatever what he meant was that it has a
soothing effect much like opium or you
know anesthesia might so it makes you
feel less bad if you live under awful
conditions and that might be true too
right so there's the sensing which both
the conservatives and marxists were
right about religion while the Horseshoe
Theory comes back to bite everybody in
the ass again it's that sort of thing
yeah what about
unemployment distinct from its effect on
wealth and poverty
yeah so unemployment is a huge predictor
of unhappiness obviously part of getting
unemployed is that you lose the source
of income and so people who are
unemployed should you know have make
less money than people who are employed
and that matters but unemployment seems
to matter beyond the loss in income and
the obvious suggestion there is that
when you lose a job it has effects like
it makes you feel redundant it makes you
feel unappreciated it makes you feel
useless you lose contact with maybe your
friends you know many people socialize
more with their friends or with
colleagues at work than with anybody
else in their their lives right you lose
contact with with that and so having a
decent job to go to seems to be really
important for human happiness even
beyond the consequences for your income
the thing about companionship again
right that's one of the things that
people talk about in this literature
seems to be really important and it
might be involved both in like the
unemployment effect and in the
religiosity effect
[Music]
have you ever looked at relative
happiness between only children and
children with siblings
I haven't you have siblings no I'm an
only child uh which is why I'm miserable
no uh it's I it makes me think
we I know this
um from a million conversations on the
show to do with the importance of having
Community the importance of having
friends
but if that's true
having not everybody gets on with their
brothers and sisters but you have a
degree of connectedness and Community
um and we've already said that you know
kids tend to move away from their
parents more quickly 18 years old 19
years old I'm off to University that's
maybe the last time that you you're
going to live with your parents that was
how it worked for me 18 years old that
was it and I never once thought oh wow
like this is that's it now probably 90
7 of the time that I'm going to spend
with my parents during my entire life is
now over
holy [__] but that's not it's wild when
you think about that when you think
about the fact that at 18 years old
you've hit some unbelievable proportion
of the amount of time that you're going
to spend with your parents it's kind of
sad in a way and you parents talk about
wanting to make the most of the time
with their children but children never
think about having to make the most of
their time with their parents and yet
it's something that all children should
be taught and yet they don't have any
perspective at all because you're 15 so
what do you care like you just don't
want to be grounded or you want to go
out and play with your friends so
I wonder what
sort of impact it does have on happiness
you know whether or not
someone who because if you're going to
move away and you go to Manchester
University and your brother or sister
goes to Newcastle University you're not
together anymore in any case right so
is there a is there a sense is there a
way in which just knowing that there is
someone out there that is a sibling that
kind of has your back so to speak does
that act as a uh a salve or an
anesthetic somehow to Life's
vicissitudes as it sort of wobbles
around
I wonder that'd be that'll be an
interesting one to look at yeah I don't
know I mean it's true that people's
relationships with their siblings vary a
lot right some are really really
functional and some really aren't and
then there's effect where if you're a
single child living with your parents
you might have more adult contact right
if you have seven siblings your parents
are going to have less time for you than
if you're an only child and so you had
the benefit of getting your parents
attention to a much greater extent than
you would have if there were six other
Chris's yeah right very good point that
depends on how likable you are as a
child though as a chronically unlikable
child so yeah I wonder whether that
offset it a little bit and then the
final one the fourth sort of Horsemen of
this happiness apocalypse is poor health
yeah so so Health right now there's one
thing about health which is that we have
a certain degree a certain ability to
adapt to it so getting symptoms is
terrible like getting a diagnosis is
terrible adapting to a new uh condition
is terrible but when it comes to so many
conditions we have an ability to live a
pretty good life nonetheless this is
often surprising to people but somebody
who would not have been surprised is
Adam Smith So Adam Smith talked about a
man who gets a wooden leg he loses a leg
in an accident he cries like a baby he
thinks his life is over he's never going
to have any fun again and then as time
passes the man realizes that he can
enjoy what Adam Smith called the
pleasures of of solitude and Society you
can still play chess you can still talk
you can still go drinking with your
friends you can do if you might could be
able to go horseback riding right
um and as you realize that things aren't
so bad your happiness might return not
quite to Baseline maybe but it's going
to get it's going to get better
so Health matters but it depends on the
extent to which it affects your ability
to enjoy the pleasures of solitude and
Society
um so and that in turn is going to
depend on conditions so my vision is
terrible right but the fact that my
vision is terrible has effectively no
consequences for the way I live my life
I live in throw a pair of glasses on and
now everything's right razor sharp
technology I can afford it right I have
a profession that allows me to wear
glasses some people even think glasses
are kind of stylish right so given these
conditions having poor eyesight makes a
no difference to my life in a different
era even just a couple of hundred years
ago I would have been dead like you know
four decades ago I would have been eaten
by a bear or a lion or or something and
this is important I think because
something similar applies to many other
conditions as well you're in a
wheelchair well depending on what
Society is set up like it might not make
that much of a difference to your
quality of life or it might have a huge
difference right you live in the
mountains of Nepal or somewhere if if
you can't get out of your house because
there's no banks or you know the doorway
is too narrow or something of course
it's going to have a massive effect on
your quality of life but it need not and
so for many of these conditions
you having the condition doesn't like
Doom you too low happiness a lot is
going to depend on the sort of
conditions under which you live which is
a decision right it's a political
decision to build a world that can
accommodate people with poor vision
wheelchairs or or whatever
is this adaptation is this what's going
on where people are becoming
acclimatized to that new level of Health
I I think I think that that's a serious
hypothesis we have a huge ability to
adapt much like we adapt to different
like levels of light in a room right our
eyes adapt and we feel much the same
independently of what the level of
lighting is we have an ability to adapt
to conditions around us to a very great
extent to some extent that might be
functional right if you end up in jail
unjustly accused of of some awful crime
you might adapt to conditions and
end up being okay even though you're
imprisoned uh right so there are
conditions when it's it's good but then
we also have an ability and a tendency
to adapt to things that are quite good
we all know people who are like
constantly whining right objectively
speaking if you live in the U.S or the
UK right now you're one of the richest
people who've ever walked the face of
the Earth right unless you've
desperately poor right now most of us
are hugely affluent by comparison to
almost everybody who's ever lived and
yet some people do nothing but complain
right and the story has got to be that
they've adapted to the riches
um they probably have genuine concerns
and genuine things to be upset about but
some people don't right and that's
certainly a sure way to make yourself
unhappy unnecessarily
fascinating Insight yeah the the health
thing is is
um of particular interest to me because
I ruptured my achilles uh two and a half
years ago so full Detachment which is a
serious injury it's a 12-month
Rehabilitation process uh it's it's not
good you've got to go through surgery
it's very painful too isn't that right
so I didn't feel anything when apart
from I knew that something had snapped
and it sounded a little bit like a gun
went off
um wouldn't advise it but
I I remember I was in the car it's the
first time I'd started playing Cricket
again and my dad and me would do this
thing it was the sport I played
obsessively throughout my sort of from
10 to 19 it was all that I did mum and
dad would come to the games especially
dad he was a fan of the sport and then
he used to come and I thought toward the
back end of kovid while I was still in
the UK I might end up going away to
America this would be an amazing thing
for me and Dad to rebond over it would
also be cool for me it's probably good
to get fresh air covid's kept me in the
house for ages when I go and play some
Cricket first game having a great time
playing great and uh bing yeah don't
take a sport back up at the age of 32
and think that you're just going to be
able to to to to do it the number of
people that I've Got Friends of that
started playing basketball again they
were basketball players at the age of
you know 14 to 21 and then they leave
University they don't play and they play
a game of pickup at 36 and they rupture
an ACL because the body is not
conditioned to this men our age 10 to
not war
yeah last time I played two decades ago
I didn't need to warm up
um so anyway my point being that at the
time it was quite distressing I'm very
big into my health and fitness I wasn't
able to do the things physically that I
wanted to
um and it's so immediate that the
inconvenience is so rapid with its onset
I remember I was late there the day
the day it happened the day it happened
or the day after it happened
and uh I was just laid up I can't do
anything until I get the surgery so I'm
not even on the road to Improvement at
this point I just have a foot which is
essentially not attached to the rest of
my leg
and I'm just laid up just feeling sorry
for myself and feeling like [__]
um and yeah it felt it felt pretty sort
of destitute and I was kind of
despondent but I knew that I was working
toward here's the next date and here's
the next date and this was probably one
of the most interesting things that I've
learned from your work which was the
difference between somebody who is
dealing with chronic pain
and somebody who is dealing with a a
malady that they are able to adapt to
can you explain the difference between
those two yeah so chronic pain is is
awful right chronic pain interferes with
basically everything you try to do uh
during your day right it's constant
reminder that that you're ill and uh
it's an obstacle in uh no matter what
you're trying to do that means that it's
very hard to adapt to something like
chronic pain you're unlikely to see a
scenario where over time you adapt to to
a baseline other sorts of conditions
might be easier to adapt to so something
like a prostate problems like many men
develop prostate cancer at some point in
their in their lives like getting a
diagnosis is is terrible right nobody
wants cancer and so on but um in so many
cases doctors will suggest I guess they
call it watchful waiting where you know
you're monitoring things and then if
you're lucky the cancer will develop so
slowly that you can die from something
else if you get killed by something else
before the cancer and then you know you
might be able to live your ordinary life
in much the same way that you did before
you got the cancer and so that sort of
thing might be quite easy to to adapt to
relatively speaking right so different
the conditions aren't the same is what
I'm saying some are easier to adapt to
and the ones that are easier to adapt to
are not going to harm your happiness
quite as much over time as the others do
yeah it's really interesting to think uh
what was the other thing there was
another example it wasn't just chronic
pain there was something else you gave
as a an example of a type of so one
study that I did we found that
incontinence was a similar had a similar
effect so people who have incontinence
will tell you that it affects every
domain of their life it affects their
dating life it affects like whether they
want to hang out with their friends it
affects their ability to go to the
movies and and things like that it's a
problem that makes itself known uh
throughout the day presumably you know
when you wouldn't want it to right and
that sort of condition is then going to
be hard to adapt to and you would expect
to see what we found which is a lasting
effect on happiness levels
for all of the people who are not living
with chronic pain or incontinence I
think we can breathe a sigh of relief
Eric agner ladies and gentlemen Eric I
really appreciate you I love the Insight
in this intersection of economics and
philosophy if people want to check out
more of the stuff that you do where
should they go
I have a book called How economics can
save the world which I recommend to
everyone have a look and maybe you'll
learn something
thank you so much Chris it was great
talking to you I enjoyed it my pleasure
thank you mate if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe